welcome to the show Donald Trump
continues to find ways to meet privately
with Vladimir Putin and to make sure
that there is absolutely no record of
these meetings and by privately I don't
just mean like not in front of
television cameras when I say privately
I mean without staff without even a
note-taker which would be totally
standard practice for meetings with
world leaders would the President of the
United States and we already learned
about this happening previously in
Hamburg Germany we've heard about it now
a couple of times in fact and now we've
learned over the last few hours that in
Argentina at the g20 summit just a
couple of months ago in mid mid-november
roughly Donald Trump again figured out
how to meet with Vladimir Putin without
any US official in the room or anybody
taking notes the only other people that
were in the room were Melania Trump and
Vladimir Putin's translator who I'll
talk to you about in a second the White
House had previously admitted that an
informal conversation took place but of
course but they didn't say that it was
with no one from the US side present
other than Melania Trump and let's talk
a little bit briefly now about Vladimir
Putin's translator this is an aside but
it's really really interesting the
entire Putin translator thing is
fascinating Vladimir Putin's translator
is also his press secretary Dmitry
Peskov so Dmitry Peskov translates for
Putin in real time at events and
meetings and he's also the press
secretary for the Putin regime one of
the primary propagandists much like
sarah huckabee sanders to donald trump
although he's probably more informed
than sara is about what's going on in
the Putin regime so this is just
brilliant hey it's just my translator
here who's Naumann nominally and
normally simply sort of a funnel conduit
through which language is translated but
he's also this very political and quite
astute diplomatic figure he was in the
room with Vladimir Putin Putin is not
actually dumb enough to have the meeting
completely by himself
so anyway Peskov is there with Putin
otherwise it's just Trump
Melania and there's a few issues here as
usual number one why does Donald Trump
keep finding ways to meet with Putin
privately with no notes and with no
American officials but it's not
happening with other world leaders Trump
has not been caught meeting privately
with you know the Chilean president for
example why is it always Russia and then
maybe more importantly we now have a
building sort of two-year gap in the
information record about what's been
discussed between our president and
Vladimir Putin especially since after
one previous meeting Trump actually sees
the notes of the American translator so
we take that and then we zoom out and we
remember that Donald Trump has been told
secrets by allies in one particular case
by Israel and then immediately spills
those secrets to a Russian spy recruiter
in the Oval Office
Trump has figured out how to have
multiple private meetings with Vladimir
Putin avoiding even note-taking or
having another US official in the room
Trump just eased sanctions on three
Russian companies controlled or
associated with Putin's crony Oleg
Deripaska we're gonna talk about that a
little bit later on in the program he
surrounded himself with pro-kremlin
aides and confidants many of whom have
now been indicted or convicted why isn't
this happening if there is nothing
unusual here with the Estonian President
or the Senegalese President or any
others it's just Putin and sometimes odd
praised for other authoritarian regimes
we've talked about Turkey we've talked
about North Korea we've talked about
Rodrigo Duterte
in the Philippines so then the last
thing is to for a second say let's
reverse our assumptions let's test our
assumptions if we assume for a moment
that Trump really isn't doing anything
wrong that nothing is going on with
Russia at all which is really difficult
to imagine at this point but pretend
just for our thought experiment if Trump
is truly totally innocent of everything
related to Russia why would he keep
doing things like this that make him
look guilty as hell any
actually innocent person would avoid
doing exactly what Trump is doing
because he's already under a storm of a
storm cloud I guess we could call it of
suspicion and under multiple
investigations it completely belies all
credulity and every single week it seems
to be even deeper and more problematic
than we previously imagined okay let's
now talk about the Russian sanctions
thing and then we'll get all the Russia
stuff just sort of out of the way at the
top of the show and move on to bigger
and better things because this is
basically as bad as it can possibly get
today's show was made possible in part
by better help.com slash Pakman better
help is a service that gives you
unlimited remote access to your own
fully licensed therapist by way of phone
video and text it's less expensive than
physically going to see a therapist in
an office and you don't need to have
insurance to use better help and they
stand behind what they do better help
has a no-questions-asked full money-back
guarantee if you're not satisfied with
your experience all of better helps
counselors are thoroughly vetted for
accreditation and experience it's all
spelled out in their Terms of Service
better help requires all of its
counselors to be fully trained and
licensed and they must have at least
three years and 2,000 hours of
counseling experience so you know that
your counselor is qualified to help you
but if you don't think your counselor is
the right fit for you better help makes
it easy to switch to a new one if you've
been thinking about getting involved
with a therapist you should really check
out better help just click the link
underneath this video